no hemos cometido ningún crimen ha
declarado ya evolucionar después de ser
acusado de crimen de lesa humanidad por
el informe final en la comisión
parlamentaria de investigación sobre el
manejo de la pandemia
su hijo flavio también de la lista de 65
personas acusadas en el informe lanzó
una carcajada cuando periodistas le
preguntaron cuál fuera la reacción de su
padre al conocer las acusaciones los
miembros de la comisión todavía tienen
que aprobar el informe por una votación
la próxima semana y quieren entregarlo y
el próximo miércoles al procurador
general de la república augusto harás el
desconocido como un aliado ilegal
bolsonaro y tendrá un mes para anunciar
si decide tomar medidas con el apoyo de
una mayoría en el parlamento
revolucionario sigue siendo protegido de
un juicio político
el relator del informe él también quiere
entregarlo al tribunal penal
internacional es cerrar la séptima
denuncia contra el presidente brasileño
que el pp y de la haya tiene que
analizar